[Musique]
quand le jazz quand le jazz est là la
java sen la java s'en va il y a de
l'orage dans l'air il y a de l'eau dans
l'U casse entre le jazz et la java
chaque jour un peu plus il y a le jazz
qui s'installe alors la rage au cœur la
java fait la mal ses petites fesses en
bataille sous sa J peu fendu elle écrase
sa gauloise et s'en va dans la rue quand
le jazz et quand le jazz est
là la java sen la java s'en
va il y a de l'orage dans l'air il y a
de l'eau dans
le gaz entre le jazz et la java quand
j'écoute bat un solo de batterie BL Java
kirale au nom de la patrie mais quand je
crie bravo à
l'accordéoniste c'est le jazz qui
m'engueule me traitant de raciste quand
le jazz et quand le
jazz la java s là Java s'en
va il y a de l'orage dans l'air il y a
de l'eau dans
l'U cas entre le jazz et la java pour
moi jazz et Java c'est du pareil au même
je me saoule à la bastiem
noircil pour moi et Java dans le fond
c'est tout comme quand le jazz dit gè la
java dit g mais quand le jazz est et
quand le jazz est
là la java la java s'en
va il y a de l'orage dans l'air il y a
de l'eau dans
l'U gaz entre le jazz et la java Jaz et
Java copain ça doit pouvoir se faire
pour qu'il en soit ASI tien je partage
en frère je donne auz m pi pour marquer
son
temp je donne à la java mes mains pour
leas de et je donne à la java mess pour
le bas de son
[Musique]
dos